Our new circle, is centered at the point 20,0 here and it has this equation.
That's amazing thought if you got it correct. We know that for this blue
circle, the radius still needs to be 50 units. This is why we still have 2500
on the right-hand side for our constant. The square root of this number is 50,
our radius. Notice that for this orange circle and for this blue circle, the y
values never changed. We're at the same height for any point along our graph.
In other words, we only shifted the graph to the right. So, the only thing we
really changed or manipulated were the x values. We moved all of our points 20
units to the right. So, the x values all increase by 20. To compensate for this
adjustment, we need to subtract 20 from all our x values to maintain the same
radius. So, for circles if we subtract something from x we really shift it to
the right that many units. So, subtracting 20 moves this circle 20 unit to the
right. So, if we add 20, we'll actually move our circle 20 units to the left. I
really recommend playing around with this equation to see how you can move a
circle around on a graph. Maybe see if you can make it go up or down.